THINGS THAT ARE ALL DOABLE RIGHT
NOW.
>> PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
WEIGHED IN ON THIS RACE TONIGHT
WITH JIMMY FALLON.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> IS BERNIE GOING TO ENDORSE
HILLARY?
>> WELL, I'M SURE THEY ARE GOING
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
>> IS HE GOING TO DROP OUT?
OR HE'S GOING TO STAY IN?
>> I'M GOING TO BE TALKING TO
HIM TOMORROW.
HE'S GOING TO BE COMING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE MAIN ROLE I'M GOING TO BE
PLAYING IN THIS PROCESS IS TO
REMIND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT
THIS IS A SERIOUS JOB.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS NOT REALITY
TV.
>> DO YOU THINK THE REPUBLICANS
ARE HAPPY WITH THEIR CHOICE?
>> WE ARE.
BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY FEEL?
SO -- ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
THAT WAS TOO EASY.
BUT -- THE TRUTH IS, ACTUALLY, I
AM WORRIED ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS,
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW WHAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
>> HE REALLY HELD HIS TONGUE
THERE.
BUT HE STOPPED SHORT OF
ENDORSING, MARK, HILLARY
CLINTON.
BUT YOU CAN TELL THAT HE'S READY
TO GET ON WITH THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, RIGHT?
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT HE'S ITCHING
TO GO OUT.
WE CAN GO BACK TO IOWA WHERE HE
VIRTUALLY ENDORSED HILLARY
CLINTON IN AN INTERVIEW WITH
POLITICO AT THAT TIME.
I THINK PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
HAD SOME VERY STRONG THINGS TO
SAY ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON AND
HOW HE WAS CLOSE TO HER.
HE HASN'T OFFICIALLY COME OUT
AND SAID IT BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WHAT'S INTERESTING RIGHT THERE
IS THAT HE DODGED IT WHEN ASKED
THAT QUESTION.
HE SAID HE'S GOING TO FOCUS ON
HOW -- TALKING ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THE JOB IS.